what you're eating in her book
yeah i've been meaning to get to it for
a while oh it's got a map at the
beginning i like it when books do that
mm-hmm
did you have an open house this morning
i rescheduled
thought you might like some company ah
well the first day of school can be
tough for stay-at-home moms now you have
to understand the kids are gone the nest
is empty they are rudderless
and
a lot of guys wouldn't even notice
but i'm not a lot of guys
i listen with my mind and if you pay
attention women will tell you what they
want by telling you the opposite of what
they want
like the other day claire was like you
have to move your car there's no space
in the garage for both of our cars and
what she's really saying is that
you know i should probably get a sports
car
i was sort of looking forward to a quiet
day i thought i'd just read maybe
go for a run later that's it great we'll
run together
you don't have to do that
i know
listening
the thing is i like to run alone and i
run kind of fast so
so
so i'm not sure you're gonna be able to
keep up with me
you're kidding right no you really think
i can't keep up with you i'm not sure
you can keep up with this conversation i
think you're forgetting that i power
walk every morning and that i wear my
special shoes with the big soles which
were designed by a doctor
yes i know
but i run
every day you really think you can run
as fast as me no phil i think i can run
much much faster
than you
boom just like that the whole day
changed it was game on she knew it i
knew it we both knew it
i just want to read
i always take the stairs two at a time i
don't even think about it anymore the
regular way would seem weird if i'll let
it go i'm faster than you
if only there was some way we could
settle this once and for all but how
you seriously want to raise me i ran a
half marathon last year wow
i'm half scared okay we do need to do
this i'll go change no no i got a
conference call but how about after that
great this afternoon sweet
two at a time took the time to start we
got to fix that step two at a time
already at the top so
what
i didn't say anything couldn't hear you
i'm cranking one of my mash-ups ah
hey
there they are
how's the first day back in prison fine
yep
what are you guys doing
your mom and i are racing to the mailbox
in sequoia and back
why i don't know oh she knows
hey buddy as soon as i'm done kicking a
little mom butt here how about i school
you in some mario kart i can't i gotta
work on my journal lame
hey uh alex you uh i have a history
paper well if you want to see a little
history being made right here really
okay
ready
are you i was born ready
i came out of the womb wearing tiny
little golden wings
i run five miles a day
there is no way i'm going to lose a
two-mile race to johnny's ski pole
saving my energy drafting off of you
you feeling cocky
yeah i am
i love it
but after seeing that t-shirt
i realized something
the first day of school
is tough on all my kids
especially the one i married
afterburner's engaged
whoo
don't choke him a smoke
and down the stretch he goes
i don't believe it
daddy wins
do you believe in miracles
you're getting better sweetheart
i
lose the race to make him feel better
maybe
but it just seemed like he could use a
win today
[Music]
you